news daily from science mission
researchers developed a method for
fabricating nanoscale electronic
scaffolds that can be injected by a
syringe in a mouse after injection the
injected mesh can be visualized and the
input output of the mesh can be
connected to standard measurement
electronics so that the indicated
devices can be addressed and used to
stimulate our record neural activity
next in a new study in the journal
Nature Neuroscience lend support to the
direct influence on creativity of genes
found in people with schizophrenia and
bipolar disorder research has found the
genetic risks course for both
schizophrenia and bipolar disorders but
significantly higher in those defined as
creative individuals with this course
approximately affair between general
population and those with disorders
themselves next mutations in the rass
gene have been shown to contribute to
human cancers in a study in the journal
Nature researchers show that bacteria
Vibrio vulnificus toxin effector domain
the 5 e.v.e lives within the switch one
region of Raz and wrap one this
inactivates ER k12 thereby inhibiting
cell proliferation the fivb can cleave
all rus isoforms and chaos and change
the morphology of cancer cells and could
be considered for the treatment of
cancer thanks for watching